I felt my first polka query would center
around the inner workings of polka
culture but it turns out I'm just
confused about the cheeks exact cache is
ten so facial hair is out is it a scar
does Voldemort exist in this world
our pokeballs Horcruxes first show
released in 1998 this is the most 1985
music I've ever heard I'm half expecting
to see rocky reminiscing while driving
and aggressively shifting gears in his
Lamborghini also where's the crowd in
this arena if ash is dreaming about
becoming the very best like no one ever
was wouldn't his dream include crowds of
people cheering for him only a few
months after Corona hit and how
terrifying is it to see people getting
licked there's a rule that animators
follow when it comes to crowds and
stadium seating the back two rows must
evolve into generic game P shapes this
animation rule is in fact the doctor
dinner does it though because it looks
like the giant Pokemon just pushed him -
Ketchum is a boy from Pallet Town double
narration well if you can't sleep you
should at least get ready for tomorrow
here watch this if this is information
ash needs to know for the beginning of
his Pokemon training for tomorrow why
hasn't he watched it already and poor
squirtle they're running out of name
ideas when they coined his I guess he's
the Launchpad McQuack of Pokemon or the
come and go of gas stations but how does
a Snowe this in fact we find out later
that Ash doesn't really know jack about
Pokemon so he would have zero clue as to
which one of these would be easier to
train it's good to have a grandfather in
the Pokemon business isn't it nepotism
[Music]
that one was also taken what a horrible
person this professor knows the balls
are empty and just lets this poor kid
open them with a hopeful heart how much
you tell him which one wasn't taken and
quit being such a P okay also why are
there no more Pokemon there are many of
each kind of species so wouldn't there
be a few of each new option and before
you head to the comments to clear this
up let me remind you that the show
should do a better job explaining all of
this your
only going to fulfill your dream and
start your Pokemon training but I'm
going to miss you so much to hang in
this world you raise a kid until he's 10
then kick him out to fight creatures
with a fishing bobber brutal
oh yes kids please love this tiny
adorable electric Mouse who will shock
the out of you if you possibly insult it
also somehow the only person who isn't
being shocked dissed by proximity is the
person delivering the important line
about rubber gloves am i shocked at the
convenience of it all
noop don't forget to change your
underwear and don't forget to go to the
doctor and get that star appearing on
your eye checked out because that's I
like you a lot oh yes the old I like you
so let me continue in a ball against
your will and if you do not comply I'll
tie you up and drag you down the street
sign of affection Cole a cicada what's
the idea here force your Pokemon to
attack the bird creature that is for
what purpose for sport is this fun why
are we poking I've pledged to get all
the pokemon in the world I just want to
know what Ash's going to an ENT doctor
to help with his insanely small nasal
passage that cannot be healthy I mean
how can even breathe this dark now he
tells me
we started this episode with an
abscessed ash watching pokey battles on
his poke a TV in his poke a room with a
poke a clock in pokey sheets I don't
believe for one second that he's
clueless as to how this whole system of
capturing creatures would work I am
confused as but he wouldn't be yeah it
wouldn't stay in the pokeball but I'm
sure just throwing a shirt over it will
work perfectly good thinking ash is this
entire series just watching ash stumble
into greatness yes the Bourbon Mon is
jealous and that's why it's attacking
forget that the entire spar was a
provoked situation and the Bourbon Mon
is just offending itself from a
predatory kid with a god complex no no
the purpose jealous
you just fished a child out of the lake
and your reaction is it's just a kid
what does she usually catch okay what if
Ash had jumped into the water and saved
Pikachu's life she immediately assumes
that Ash is a jerk and well he obviously
is which begs the question is anyone in
this show someone to root for it is not
Pikachu's lightning column of death
kills all the bad Bourbons and ends the
storm it also apparently charged this
bike to ashes but leaves Pikachu ash and
all surrounding foliage completely
intact I don't know what the [ __ ] that
means but I'm sitting it and where are
the burb carcasses this show feels like
an edible that had potential but it sort
of duds out rather than Peaks this
trippy tingle bird flapping into a
rainbow is the peak and Friends it ain't
that high one most wondrous place the
incredible world of Pokemon super great
job narrating the end and ramping up to
the adventures that await but maybe a
better use of everyone's time is getting
this tiny creature to a hospital because
I think he just died
[Music]
[Music]
for some reason you all want to wear the
cinemasins pitchfork em on your body so
we slap that car on some new merchant
threw it in the store
posters hoodies tanks socks below the
YouTube player click the store link get
cinemasins calm I am ash groovy at least
you get the chance to meet me Gary Gary
King do because you don't like me their
journey is destined to be packed with
non-stop action millions of laps are
pounding perils and endless excitement
other side effects include constipation
clubfoot lockjaw